[Music]
how are you I know you dyed your hair
red no no that looks real that's uh that
was clearly an homage to Conan I'm
guessing obviously yeah this is for a
film role I'm guessing I did it for a
film role I did a couple months ago
called pitch perfect but now I just
chopped it all off and kept it reading
it red
I am I am trying to figure out if
redheads have more fun they do not know
no you know you're gonna do fine with it
just my experience with a few things in
common besides the right hair you're a
dog person right I have a dog you know
what kind of dog you have
I am mud I rescued her from a pound and
she's she's a good dog I mean I've had
her for like two years now and I
recently got her actually at a dog
training because I trained her wrong
actually you trained her dog incorrectly
yes I know that training them in general
is probably a good thing but I thought
it would maybe be funny to train her in
a cartoon voice which was really more
from my benefit than hers obviously so
you know when I trained her her growing
up I always say like come on I mean this
should be like and this you go and we
would you know do things together but
now she only does commands when I do
that cartoon voice oh I've like said
Billy
and she'll do nothing but had to go like
sad barely saw and then show like you
said that's terrible if like like if a
burglar breaks into your home you're
like
it's really really sad it's it I don't
know an especially a dinner parties when
people come over and like I'm like oh
God and those people over and I have to
be right there I say that's it let's do
that and then I got a dog trainer and
the dog trainer told me that my dog is
insecure wait I think would be being
trained in a cartoon works I'm sure that
there is probably some mental problems
which sounds really terrible but yeah
she said that my dog is insecure because
the dog knows that you're using a like a
silly voice I guess because she's like
you know controlling or yeah she all she
said was insecure and that one day you
left the house and your dog thought
everything was fine and then turned on
the TV with its paw and saw cartoons you
know yeah we saw Spongebob and was like
she's making fun of me I know it sounds
like of a terrible mother but every
morning I actually say to her you know
you is smart you was calm it was
important to raise her confidence I
swear to God and my friends make fun of
me because they're like this doesn't
really work what I say like subliminally
I think she knows was this at the
trainer's advice I don't think you know
me so once again you've come up with
something crazy on your own